all right for people
joining this live stream we are talking
about compiled layers for neural
networks
for upcoming version 12.2 of
language all right so where have we got
to last time
we had stripped out some of the some of
the kind of
giant dogs being wagged by tiny tails i
believe
but can you show what you mean by that
what's that i'm not sure what you mean
by that
uh well i mean there were some whole
mechanisms that were giant
language redesigns that weren't going to
happen as a result of this
but hopefully those have all been
stripped out right all the things to do
with
named um well okay when should you go
through what you want to go through here
um yes so so this i think we we kind of
saw last time right so compiled layer
first argument is a function so getting
argument is a gradient
propagator or gradient propagating
let me just see the the thing so so the
function f
is going to be applied to the input and
yeah well the grain propagator actually
you can see it in section just below
it's uh actually it has the wrong name
it's called backward function here but
anyway
same thing um so
this this takes the output gradient
and gives back the input gradient okay
that's kind of uh
that that's its role it's propagating in
the in the reverse direction the the
gradients of the layers
argument order correct how can it give
back the input if the input is one of
the inputs
uh gradient exactly
the output of this function is the
gradient
of the eventually the loss of the
network okay but so if this was a
derivative function what you're calling
input which is the point of evaluation
of the gradient
would be the thing that is fed in as a
curried piece
right so that's the input of the
function yeah
right so i mean if i say d f of x
comma x right the thing i get
is f prime this thing that you're
representing here
is supposed to be the f prime which
would have in your notation that would
be something like
you know backward function of
and then it would say whatever the
function is
and then the input would be a thing that
was fed to it is that correct
uh except backward function also gives
you the the derivative
multiplied by an output gradient
so so yeah this is this is where this
design we looked at very briefly last
week
that i had for this adjoint derivative
sort of
comes in and maybe it's worth looking at
the page i have for that
okay yeah we have yeah we have a bullet
about automatic differentiation there
so what should i look for it's called
adjoint derivative
no actually it's we're not going to use
that
so for for our universe this is the
concept i want
to see okay the concept fine fine yeah
okay so what is an adjoint derivative
represents delta
what is delta is delta an operator here
or is delta scalar delta's a
delta in this case in that first one
it's a scalar
in the second one it's a it's a vector
okay so that says
i don't understand this notation at all
so i would have thought that from a
mathematical point of view this is some
kind of
i mean if if you've got a a scalar field
f of whatever or a
scalar function of position what is this
this is some kind of
you know tangent vectory thing is it not
where does this normal vectory thing
okay
but does this thing live i mean the
derivative
sort of lives in some kind of tangent
bundle where does this thing
live what kind of an object is it
a joint derivative of delta what is that
delta leads in this output output space
of the function right delta is in the
output space
so remember we had this other other
right
definition and this was done to be
similar to this which is directional
derivative which is much easier for
people to understand
but directional derivative has the
direction here
of the function and then where it is
being evaluated where it has been
evaluated
exactly okay so this is this is sort of
it's trying to make an analogous syntax
but now delta is in the function space
versus the um input space
so why is it in that argument position
i mean isn't it isn't it rather adjoint
derivative of
f and then this delta
is telling you kind of how far to go in
a particular direction or some
is it a direction what is it explain to
me what this thing actually is
it's a direction in the function space
so it's a combination
it's a combination of the function
um so wait a minute so you're taking
the value and you're saying
yeah okay where is the
this is in no f
applied to x f of x
what happens with a univariate case is
there a univariate case
yeah there's a univariate case but what
happens consider it consider it as a
vector of one thing
probably the the thing that might make
it most easy to understand
is the is the third note
which says for a vector-valued function
adjoint derivative is equivalent to
the gradient of delta dot f
how can there be a delta over a
vector-valued function right for a
vector okay
so projection of the function in some
direction yep
and then it's the derivative
it's the gradient it's the gradient with
respect to the
at a point at which you are looking at
the dir the the
okay i understand precisely precisely
and i
and again this is this is just not i
don't have i don't even think the name
is right
um the argument order can change it's
the concept i think we really need
something for
okay hold on this is very helpful by the
way
so hold on let me think yeah so
this is
a function dotted into the vector
so
i'm sorry a vector dotted into the
function
so in a sense you're really taking a
derivative
of i mean otherwise this would be a
gradient
i mean just to write this out this is
basically gradient
of and then it's your
vec dot f
of x with respect to x precisely
okay and for some reason you want to
write this whole thing
as a function yeah okay i can see why
you're doing it in the order you're
doing it
it makes some sense okay
all right so then explain to me how that
relates to this backward function here
well because that's exactly what you do
in neural networks when you do back
propagation
but okay so i'm i'm i'm saying so you've
got an argument order
you've got explain to me so so
so the the goal of um by propagation
is to compute the derivative of the loss
with respect to all the weights
right yep and so you start from the top
of the network just there
just the loss and uh and then you step
by step
compute the derivative of let's say one
let
of the loss with respect to one layer
and then to obtain the derivative of
of another layer oh sorry of the loss
with respect to another layer
you multiply this first derivative so
derivative of the loss with respect to
layer
n let's say you multiply it by um
i mean that's okay basically you apply
the backward function
i mean what we call the grain
propagating function to obtain
the derivative of the loss with respect
to the layer n minus one
so that's why we talk about output
gradient this is a direction
in the function space but for us it's
actually the derivative of the loss
with respect to the output of the
function
and and then we we we compute the
derivative of the loss with respect to
the input
of the function using this gradient
propagating function
which is exactly the same thing that rob
and what's the output doing there
the output is a commodity because often
uh because the fact is in the neural
network you have the output you computed
it already and sometimes it's faster to
reuse the output you can express
the gradient uh with respect to the
input
with the output a simple example is
is you know think of think of this for
the exponential function
um this is not layer related but you
know you
the output is x of x well the derivative
also is x of x so y computed twice
exactly exactly so the
you at least need the output gradient
for sure
uh often if you have the input it's
faster
actually actually not faster now if you
have the sometimes you need the input
just
let's let's zoom out for a minute okay
ethernet live stream is suggesting we
look at swift tensorflow and talking
about differentiable languages in
general
what does it mean to be a differentiable
language what does it mean you have a
piece of code
and the piece of code in general is some
function f of x that has all kinds of
stuff inside it
what does it mean to be able to
differentiate that piece of code
well that's that's what i've i've worked
on you know last year and this year is
this automatic differentiation i
understand that i want to know
given that i have a function which is
defined by a piece of code
right so imagine that we have f of x
blank colon equals blah blah blah blah
blah
right now you want to be able to compute
f prime of x blank in some sense of f
prime and you want to be able to do that
by symbolically looking at the code
right that's what you're trying to do am
i correct
effectively yes okay what's the
effectively part
well we we look at the symbolic the
symbolic version of the code by
by you know reducing it to a code graph
which is what
the compiler does i understand that but
but that's
from the point of view of the user you
wrote a piece of code
it's computing jacob and that's the goal
right the derivative which is like
the derivative of all the outputs with
respect to all the inputs that's a
general thing you try to compute okay so
we got a function we don't try to
compute that
actually that's that's the goal right no
the goal is
is to get either of a forward forward
derivative or a backward derivative
which does not compute the whole
jacobian
but then you you combine them to anyway
so the goal is
to compute the dot product of the
jacobian win either exactly okay let's
keep it much simpler
okay this is a thing that says f of x
blank colon equals code
and let's assume the code returns a
scalar
right so then in principle
we could ask for the you know let's call
it the automatic
derivative of f isn't that just f prime
it is basically f prime but it but this
is giving
the issue is i mean so you know the
question is can we compute
f prime given this definition
can we compute f prime right now what
will be our language way of representing
that idea of computing f prime that's
that's exactly what this adjoint
derivative and directional derivative
things i have are for is well
english representation for those okay
but but so how would you actually write
it so let's say
i've got f of x blank colon equals x
plus two okay or more interestingly
let's say
nest you know um
plus one you know
ampersand uh i don't know what
i'm gonna let let me be really mean and
say something like this
okay let's say i have something like
that that's non-differentiable but it's
okay right okay so
let's let's say something like this
right okay so now what am i going to do
what do i then compute here you you
either compute
the adjoint derivative
well i just want to know what do i
actually type yeah so
what would so so so let me explain what
automatic differentiation does
because it doesn't it doesn't compute
the whole jacobian it computes either
it computes either a directional
derivative which is called the forward
mode
or it computes this this adjoint thing
we've been talking about which is called
the reverse or backward mode
so it it it avoids compute so you can do
one of those two things
now you can compute the whole jacobian
by applying it a bunch of times
but that's not typically what what we're
not talking about jacobians here we've
got we've got a scalar function
so just tell me so what what what you
can use either so so one way to do it
there are two ways to write one is
adjoint derivative
i'm not liking this already i'm not
liking this this is a
i just want to do a very simple thing
i'm taking this function f of x blank
i want to find its derivative using
automatic differentiation how do i do it
right a derivative of one
of f of whatever
x you want to to apply it to okay and
then what this is going to give me
is some automatic differentiation
function some interpolating function
like object
that i mean this would give me some
interpolating function like object is
that correct
well the only case we can do it for is
is
when it can be compiled so it would be a
compo code function object
okay all right okay fine so but but the
the case we can do it for
is a case where we can get a symbolic
result is that correct
no no i mean it's where we can compile
we can compile i don't care about
compilation i'm saying i'm asking the
question
if i feed in if it's done with
compilation
what what is it computing it's computing
a numerical approximation
to the derivative is that true or no
it's exact it's exactly
anymore you didn't answer my question
then then okay so hold on
hold on hold on the many different
things going wrong here
okay whatever we can do with the
compiler we could do with code
we can go with code transformations if
it's an exact symbolic result
whatever the compiler is doing is also
something
achievable with code transformations is
that not correct
i'll let tom comment on that it's
obviously true i mean from what you just
said it's obviously true
you make a an execution graph code graph
whatever
it's obviously true right tom can do you
want to comment on that
i i'm i'm hazy about that
okay so i'm not hazy it's either true or
what you're saying is total nonsense
right it's
it's in other words this is not a magic
numerical scheme
this is something where you take the
code graph i mean let's take the most
basic yes it is it is a code
transformation
right let's take a very basic case what
the compiler is giving is
is effectively is is equivalent
you know isomorphic with a lambda
representation
a pure lambda right so so then why don't
you explain to me
in in the case of i mean a lambda is
a trivial lambda is trivially
differentiable
right so a lambda gets non-trivial when
it has conditionals and things like that
in it right
right okay so we can perfectly well take
something like this does does d work for
inactivated things
well doesn't really matter if x is
greater than zero
x squared otherwise x cubed
well that case is much easier than the
other case you had with something like
nest
of course it is now way back way back
when stephen
i this is when i worked on derivative
you know d
like 10 years ago i wrote there there's
a system option
which which allowed you to do this
symbolic automatic
differentiation and you know i have
it hasn't been maintained so it doesn't
really work anymore but it's exactly the
concept you're talking about but it
could only handle pretty simple things
okay but so my question is okay so so i
understand that so
given the code graph i don't understand
what isn't just symbolic transformation
of of
the code i don't see why it has anything
to do with the compiler i mean other
than the compiler
happens to have code in it that can do
the the relevant analysis
because the the the the the way
the way it's the way it's written it
uses this single static analysis
what is its ssa single static analysis
yeah assignment sorry right
um and so when you're equivalent to a
lambda representation
yes fine it's an immutable thing that
it's just
right that's the point it's not doing
it's it's unrolling it to the point
where you don't have variables
correct that's exactly correct that's
100 correct
right so if you could write the thing in
terms of combinators or pure lambdas
then then this is a procedure for giving
you the derivative right
that's correct i believe that yes that's
a good statement okay so then
then in principle your compiler code
should allow one we could use the
analysis code in the compiler
to take any expression that we have here
and write it
in this static immutable combinatory
form
correct
must be true from what you're saying it
must be true that i can take
that expression nest or whatever and i
can write that
in this as something involving immutable
combinators yes
yes right okay so we could explicitly
generate that symbolic form
if we wanted to am i making sense
right that must be a part of the past
some parts of the compiler must do that
right tom
is that correct tom i'm sorry
that is a non-trivial question in in
some
abstract sense yes um
okay well so so i'm telling you it must
work because
the the fact is in the compiler right
the question is this there is a trivial
sense in which you can do this you
basically write
nest in terms of combinators right you
can clearly do that
right it may be a big messy thing then
your challenge is to simplify that
expression
you know as best you can to make it and
and that is the that is a pruning that
will depend on type analysis
and depend on various kinds of analyses
and theorems that you can prove in the
compiler
well typically the type analysis is done
first
yeah but but that's that's just to
convenience it doesn't matter
right you know yes that probably avoids
you making a very bushy tree that you
don't need to make
see what i'm saying i mean
right
okay look you guys are going at this a
bit the wrong way i'm sorry
you know this is too muddy this has
nothing to do with the compiler has
nothing to do with numerical analysis
it's a symbolic transformation
of a symbolic expression that we have
and we have great tools for manipulating
symbolic expressions
which for some reason we're choosing not
to use because we've learned automatic
differentiation
in it you know from people who don't
have those symbolic tools
and so we're very confused that's my
my summary i've thought about symbolic
differentiation used in our symbolic
tools and
it's not not i mean i have a you know a
prototype i wrote
um that uses symbolic stuff but it's
right you know it's very simple it's
very slow you get expression soil you
get lots of problems
right right okay so then the question is
go ahead i mean the result of the
automatic dimension
i mean is a program that complete
derivative
but the way this program looks um
i mean i'm not sure we are in agreement
when you say expression like it's
it's it's not a classic symbolic
expression
what is that i mean it's first i mean
you have imagined that a program
the trace of the program is always
different i mean it can potentially be
different when you run it
so what is the code what does the code
look like
i think it runs it runs the program i
mean i don't care about running the
program
what the code that's what it does code
the code i mean what's
the algorithm first run the program for
sure
then it remembers a trace and every
value
internal value of the program during
this trace
and then it goes uh to to compute
derivative
of everything with respect output
respect to everything
and come back that's what it does yup
okay so for many years now
by many i mean 40 i have thought about
this question of how do you store
symbolic execution traces
right we have a function called trace
that tries to do that not very
successfully
but what you're describing is i mean
what you need to do though
realistically is not just run the
program once but run all possible
versions of the program with all
possible branches
because in general to make a piece of
code
that allows you to have these you know
to have the
derivatives taken right your your
you know you need to do all possible
branches of the program don't you
no no see that's the whole thing that's
the beauty of this single static
assignment thing it allows us to
to use these fee instructions that are
in there to
handle each branch sort of on its own
so we we effectively differentiate each
branch of that
so you're saying given a particular
input to the program
you're asking right so given the
particular input the program runs in a
particular way
yeah okay so let's let's zoom out for a
minute okay
so you're saying your older effort was
given a program in general
without constraints on its input what
can you symbolically do to define the
derivative of the program
right right that's thing number one
right
now you're saying thing number two is
given a particular input for a program
what you want to do is make small moves
around that particular input
finding in effect the derivative of you
know x plus epsilon x minus epsilon
you're effectively trying to find those
derivatives around
that value correct exactly and that's a
key
that's a key thing in the automatic
differentiation because if you try and
you know represent the program as the
whole thing it
you know no no i understand so but the
point then is what you're trying to do
is to compute that rather than computing
x plus epsilon x minus epsilon finding a
finite difference
right you're trying to compute it why do
you save more than
a factor of like three or four by doing
this
because the number of inputs let's say
you have 100 inputs
you have to to do some epsilon on the
100s of them
okay all right so good answer yeah yeah
okay and there's and and there's there's
also other ways this can be used as
adjoint derivative concept
so so for both nd solve and
and this this parametric optimization we
talked about last week
there's this concept of of getting the
gradient with respect to all parameters
we don't have a way of expressing that
now
and for say a femme solution with you
know a thousand
degrees of freedom and the initial
condition you want to find the
sensitivity to that
like you need this concept i get it so
let's let's walk through the concept
that you have here
okay so what you're saying is we got a
function
and the function in general has a whole
vector
of inputs right which could be 100
inputs
yeah right and what you're saying is you
want
the what you're asking for is
essentially i don't even know the
mathematical notation for that
it's sort of the full derivative with
respect to all possible changes in v
yeah but that's the that's the gradient
right
well if this is a scalar valued function
that is the gradient yeah why is it
check again
no it's a scalar value function it's the
gradient right but in general
it's jacobian in general it's well no
see what you want
what which what you want is not the full
jacobian because that's
that's typically impractical but it
depends on your application
it's i agree that to compute the
i mean for optimization which is the
case we're interested it's always a
scalar function
so so indeed the internal um
sorry the internal layers for us we
don't want to complete jacobin for them
it's impractical you want to propagate
and never have to compete in jacobian
but but you could have a function that
has to output and that's the goal i mean
that's the
yeah so you can always compute that by
finding the two
you know with this joint you can find
the adjoint in the direction of the
first component now joint and direction
so the point is that the functional that
we have for derivative
is with respect to a particular slot i
mean what we're doing is derivative
one f yeah right it's taking but now
that slot with our derivative here
we're not actually committing ourselves
to whether that slot is a vector value
or not are we i mean this is we've
always done this we've always imagined
this is a scalar computation
oh but but try try
if you do d i'm trying to oh if you do
say d
of f of list of x comma y
comma x look at what you get
okay so this is a derivative
so in a sense what you're saying is it's
a it's an
all up there what you want here
is something which represents
not just this but all possible unit
vectors here
correct that would be the gradient will
be the list of all possible
choices of unit vector here
yes correct well yeah but but it's it's
a combination of
right it's it's a determination it's
what's the vector
for all possibles that's what i said
yeah it's a list
of the results for all possible unit
vectors yes that's correct
okay
so i'm wondering
so and you could imagine so in a sense
this thing
what is the right name for it it is
almost you know the full derivative
of and then it's asking
for the dimension d it's uh it's saying
basically what we want to do
and where do we have a notation for this
you're saying
on that dimension d i mean this is this
is the collection of unit vectors here
we do we have another function that has
that has a notation
for something where we are yes it's
basically selecting
it's like part selection where we're
just taking a list
it's like a ray at that point right
because what array is doing
is it's taking you know this thing here
and what we're doing here yeah what we
need is something which is then going to
return
yeah i mean you need to have it be more
general because it's got to be able to
do
multi you know derivative with respect
to the first argument of this which can
have many different pieces
second argument and so on is this making
some sense
right right that's yep
okay so now what you're saying is
what happened i think the second
argument of d you can put several
things right and uh like in the list or
list of lists
no that that's something different list
well list of lists i'm not sure about
but a single list
is differentiation of um
yeah okay great so that's that
so that is indeed the gradient vector
yes
okay all right so then
then what we need is
okay and what you're saying is given a
program
you can go through in that program and
you can
assuming that the program doesn't assign
values to variables
assuming you've managed to make the
program one that is sort of enough
combinator like that it doesn't do that
then this thing is purely
function composition then so then every
individual
sort of uh variation as you go through
the program
is composable it's like chain rule is
that right
because it's essentially function
composition am i right
yes yes it is it is effectively the
chain rule
but to see the thing you compute for
that for every possible input
is is for scalars you can
compute those values for scalars okay so
if
f has multiple components you need to
make that into a scalar to be able to do
that
and that's where that delta i have comes
in so you take
take that combination yeah i get it i
mean that's a
that seems to me a detail of you're
taking
i mean okay you you're trying to compute
the scalar because
in i mean ultimately you are writing the
innards of your function
in the form you know f of g of h of
whatever it is
right where the fgh could be things that
have ifs in them and all kinds of weird
stuff
yep right okay so then
and ultimately what you're doing is
you're just computing
this thing here but you're doing so by
um okay
and and the final function that you get
going through all of our you know system
functions and so on is it representable
in terms of symbolic things that we have
or is it something where in the end
in other words let's say one of those
fgh was some weird hypergeometric
function
right we would presumably
compute numerical derivatives of that
weird hypergeometric function unless we
could unless it was
you know exactly evaluatable we'll see
this
um right but it's possible see so for
some weird function like hypergeometric
function
it's it's possible that if we could we
could attach a definition
of adjoint derivative to that or you
know whatever we want to call this cause
no it's not an adjunct derivative it's
just the freaking derivative
for by the time you get down to an
individual function here
in this stack of things that represents
the thing you're trying to compute
it's just a derivative i mean if it's a
seven argument hypergeometric function
okay there's some special cases there
but basically
by the time you're down at these
individual functions
i think it's just a derivative
there's nothing that's a scalar function
yes if it's a scalar function it's just
the gradient
or or the forward right the the
direction right but
so the thing i'm saying is sandra on the
live stream is pointing out the
what i'm calling full derivative if the
k if it was instead of a list it was a
sum it would be the total
derivative that's correct um
i mean this is a generalization of of
total derivative so to speak
to be able to in a sense apply an
arbitrary function
to collect together the individual
directional derivatives basically
the or the when i say directional i mean
on the coordinate directions of the
vector which is not obviously what you
mean by
a um right we'll see that's why i have
this other thing i call directional
derivative which does the
sort of this this other thing it
actually does compute the directional
derivative
but it uses it uses a slightly different
technique
to do that okay
let's zoom out for a minute here
okay so what we're trying to do you know
the general thing we want to do
is given a piece of code we want to be
able to represent
the uh you know given a piece of code
and a particular input to that piece of
code
we want to find the derivative of that
code near that piece of input
right that's that's the that's the final
thing we want
correct typically in a particular
direction
in the output space well if the output
is a vector yes if the output was a
scalar
yes if the output is a scalar that's
exactly what we want steve
this this i think for our application
uh yes because we're only interested in
function that have one
in the end we're only interested in
optimization and so in functionality
scala
but i think there are other applications
where they also care
of having the jacobian so sorry to say
that again but i think oh no yes the
faux jacobian is useful but in many
cases it's not so so suppose you want to
find the derivative
again i'll go back to nd solve
parametric and desolve so suppose you
want to find the sense the
derivative with respect to say an
initial condition
for some for some pde okay
you're not going to practice getting the
full jacobian may be
you know a ten thousand by ten thousand
major okay so so let's
let's just parameterize what we're
talking about here okay so so
so this is
okay so what we're saying is that
um what we want let's call it just for
now let's call it a d
of a function f
at a particular position
right at an input so that the first
thing we want
is just this right where this is going
to give us something which has the same
dimensions as
that input space right assume it's a
scalar function
yeah so so that would be reverse
automatic differentiation why is it
reversed
well there are two different types of
automatic differentiation there's a
forward and a reverse
okay a four computes the directional
derivative the reverse
computes the gradient okay so this is
backward i mean it's uh it's an
implementation right it's because it's
faster
because in that case your function is a
scalar it's always faster
to apply the chain rule in the backward
direction
starting from the output to the input
all right okay so this gives
so in this case we're giving gives
the derivative
of f at input
right okay so now
there's a different case you say yeah
which is the forward case
where you're saying we are given
the output and the input presumably
how do we you're just given the input so
okay so what do i do now so i've i've
got this thing id of f
of input okay and then there's some
direction
direction in the in the input space in
the input space exactly
okay okay and then what does what do i
do with that direction
that it gives it gives the
directional derivative in that i see
okay okay jacobian dotted with that
direction okay
so directional derivative
in a certain direction right and that's
a simpler that's simpler than the
backward automatic differentiation and
it can do it it doesn't in one pass so
it basically only costs twice as much
as the function evaluation okay so this
particular thing here
this one here so that okay so case one
okay so look case one
is returning a well actually okay so
let's enumerate these so case one
returning
a list of the same shape
as the input
okay yes and then case zero
which is the full jacobian case
return a list which is the outer product
of input and output is that correct
yes
okay case three
so this is case two rather
is your is the case where you are
um it's returning a list the same shape
as the output
right users okay um
takes dots a direction
into the input
returns a list of the same shape as the
output
right on and in case one is the same but
with the transpose of the jacobian right
and like like you dot on the other
level now well okay so this one here we
could
um for a vector valued function
uh could think of this
as dotting with a
fixed vector with a vector against the
output
what's actually yeah yes right
that's interesting there's a mention of
a chap called conal
elliot who was an employee of ours a
long long time ago i have no idea what's
happened to him
says he's working on machine learning
from perspective of type functional
languages
it's interesting look what he's done he
was a
bright guy a bit theoretical for what we
um
were doing 30 years ago
um okay
all right so in any case this is so
these are the cases we're dealing with
here
right so now
each one of these needs some kind of
design and maybe they need the same
design
um but the way these work
you say is you're unraveling
you're you're representing the code in
this
essentially combinator form and i don't
know whether the compiler could emit
as part of its intermediate code could
simply omit
that combinator form connect
tom christopher anybody you comment on
that
i mean it it it can for for sure
it's it's quite limit i mean you know it
needs
type analysis to sort of you know run
this and it needs access
to all of the functions so like your
floor case
i i don't quite know how it would
unless it knew that floor was
you know so i'm i'm walking through what
with the goal
the goal is if you can represent this
thing as f
of g of h or whatever right as a pure
functional composition story
right then then automatic
differentiation
is straightforward right so the question
is
can you represent things in that form
and the answer is
you have to do type analysis to know
whether that will work
right so given a particular type so this
is going to be a function
that has a certain type that has certain
types of input certain types of output
and then the question is can you write
it in that form because you don't need
to use
i don't know what you're doing with the
inners of the compiler but most of what
the compiler does
you know generating lvm code or
something is irrelevant
language code out of it that that would
be very interesting that that actually
would be interesting tom i mean that's
that's
totally fantastic i i i've often wanted
to do that
okay so fine but but let me just
understand what the objectives are
pretty freaking weird though
it might just look like a big goddamn
mess of lambda functions
that's fine maybe with lambda constructs
that we don't have like let's wreck
for example we you know what do you mean
we don't
have it of course we have it right what
what aspect of that do we not have
actually we we could have a with
um we we we don't have a let let rec
so what does that do well
what what it would be like with where
the bindings for the variables were
available in the right hand side
that would be like with recursive that
that would be useful actually
okay
[Music]
how would you write a with no no
all you're saying tom is this you're
saying that
the bane of all lambda calculus
everything like this
is that you ultimately need to name
variables in order to not be confused
about what's happening
when you go through nested functions
well
yes except you have this sort of cop-out
thing which is that you know the these
combinators
you know ylw combinators that implement
recursion without giving things names
absolutely absolutely full theorem
now another slightly weird thing is i
don't think these combinators can be
typed but that's that's
you can type them you can not the
recursive well you you need
infinite types right the combinators
are themselves the symbolic expressions
which are the combinator expressions
have to be included in the type calculus
but these combinators for recursion they
have to be have infinite types
it's not no they just have to have a
type schema
they just have to have a type schema
same way you would make an axiom schema
and i'm sure there's a way of thinking
about it in terms of you know just like
you can do higher order logic to think
about
quantifying over functions i'm sure you
can do this i think i think
they'll be getting getting off topic and
i'd like no tom
tom the important differences at great
length on this and
right well i think that i think it's i i
think you will find
that you can do it using a type schema
which is directly analogous to an axiom
schema in axiomatic theories
okay so for example induction okay which
is the analog of what you're talking
about the induction axiom
a piano arithmetic is not a finite axiom
it's an axiom that depends that is
essentially a generator of an infinite
class of axioms
but in fact one of the things in fact
jonathan just did this in our theorem
prover
is to turn that axiom into a single
higher order logic axiom
by quantifying over functions and i'm
sure you can do the same thing here
and and yes that is a slightly you know
that's slightly fancy and abstract
i mean the compiler is first order logic
so
you just get one level of type for all
there's no
nesting of i'm aware i'm aware but what
i'm saying is
by by in order to do what you are
describing i'm pretty sure you have to
go to second-order logic
right and there is surely a type
analysis
um uh you know what many languages
have have a second second order logic so
that's
that would be let recursion in
[Music]
sorry fine
polymorphism in function arguments
that's that like haskell i don't think
there's any variant to pascal that does
that
for example
um but yes it would be very interesting
to generate
to to to to generate some sort of
warfare language
output from the from from our
intermediate language i think that would
be super interesting
so so i'm just trying to understand okay
so let's zoom out this meeting for a
second okay
so to what extent we're trying to put
something into compiled layer
for version 12.2 that represents some
kind of automatic differentiation it is
going to be a hack
because we don't understand this
properly yet
right for 12.2 we won't have automatic
differentiation
it's uh it's you have to specify the
this what we call grain propagator which
is directional derivative
okay do we know whether we're specifying
the right thing here
so um
so in terms of the function the argument
the order of the arguments so
our logic is that the output gradient is
always needed
to compute the the input gradient
um the input is is almost let me make a
suggestion
let me ask a suggestion for for kind of
um
uh defensive design here okay
let's make the second argument to
compiled layer be something
like um you know uh
you know whatever you want to call it
gradient propagator arrow
whatever your function is okay because
if it turns out
i mean i don't know whether if it turns
out that this and you can you can say
you can in general that can be an
association because it might need other
parameters in it
but you can alight it to not have the
association around it
it's it's very very very standard
um that's how every framework uh are
created
that are lower level than ours
you know you you you you define your
your your backward program
i mean listen yeah listen we will end up
throwing away compilation yeah
yeah we will end up throwing it away so
you can you can take it
you can make a choice either compiled
layer is a throwaway
or you can defensively design this piece
of it
i don't think really think this is a
high cost because i think that
this is you know nobody you know this is
a complicated thing to write anyway
yeah yeah but it's okay i mean look i
i don't think compiled layer will
survive anyway so
you know i think it's useful for right
now i think that there'll be a bunch of
things that need to be changed about
it and in fact i suspect that
the very concept of compiled is just
doesn't make any sense because any layer
you know in the end this will be a
custom layer or function
function layer function layer will
probably use
all right well then fine i mean have
this be a
thing you can have it work however you
want okay
i think it's yeah it has some nice thing
i mean it's really because we have
compiled function
and you know the fact that you have the
rank specified in the function that are
ready to be compiled
this helps us a lot because um
we can for example we don't have to
specify if this function needs to work
on a single example on a batch of
example
we can infer it anyway there's a bunch
of things that are
so given where we are in the development
cycle i assume you've already
implemented all this stuff
yes mate has something running in the
last uh last version
just this last thing automatic batching
that we need to do
look i'm telling you make an association
of crud that you're going to put in here
you're going to need all kinds of things
here
just put in an association that has all
these kinds of weird options
there's no way we can do this this is
this is gonna put it i don't think we're
gonna put this batch uh thing yeah
uh it's something that yeah i don't
think we're gonna put it this is
we don't need it okay fine then let's
not let's not discuss it
yeah this is the okay this is for later
to have multiple ports okay that's a
different
multiple ports i don't even understand
what that is in terms of what we've been
defining up here let's
let's review again what we're doing here
so i think i understand this
better now this is a very nice thing
which we should have and in in some
sense
you know thinking about it a bit more is
is the argument
you know i'm not sure i have the organ
or in these design ideas
but right part of the directional
derivative was
was came from discussion with jose which
is why i use that analogous
analogy um you know because
um well yes i mean i understand why
coming from the tensor calculus point of
view i understand why you would end up
with that and and i think i think having
something that would give the
effectively give the full jacobian is is
a reasonable thing but i think it should
perhaps be a different function
look i think the right answer here which
we don't have yet and it's going to take
more design grinding
is there is a design which gives the
full jacobian
and that designer lies down to cases one
and two
when it has a slightly simpler input
form that's what i think i think it's a
single thing
that does all of these cases and
that it's simply illusions that give the
other the cases
one and two that's what i think and i
think that the way to think about what's
happening inside
is um
you know to be able to write i think
it'd be useful thing just like in
boolean algebra
right we have you know if you look at
boolean
boolean minimize okay if i say
you know a and not b
or c or something like this and i say
and i don't know all these things but i
say what do we have i thought we had a
bdd
or is it boolean convert let me remind
myself how this works
oh yeah anf for example
okay so what this is doing
is this is essentially a simple compiler
right this
is combining compiling into you know
xor and and type format
right and what what effectively we're
saying is what we want to do here
is which is rather interesting is to
take a piece of symbolic code
and compile it into something which is
this single assignment aka immutable aka
combinator
structure
and to do that i think tom is
uh probably right that
we will end up having to have him we're
just introducing
these combinators for version 12.2 we're
introducing the traditional schonfinkel
combinator structure
but that gives us a pattern for
i mean yes we may need i mean that that
actually gives us
the ability to do certain kinds of
uh variable you know recursive variable
binding type
things i think it might just be a with
recursive
actually is what might be sufficient i i
i am
you know but it with recursive would be
useful
what would it do well right with
recursive recursive
right and then you do like um
parenthesis f equals function
what write it write this okay f equals
function
and then bracket x bracket x
comma in the body of the function x
comma
um then like if x equals zero
you know one yeah comma
x times f x minus one
right okay yep and then close the thing
and then comma
you know f type f of 20 or something
so this is different from with because
the bindings
are available in the right hand you know
available as you make them
you see so that's that that is like hold
on hold on hold on hold on
that wouldn't work with with you're
saying no you can't do that with with
because with is
with f the binding for f is not
available when you make the binding
you see yeah right
i i'm pretty sure that's like let rec
yeah it is a lot of lambda languages add
sugar
for these things um
i don't know why because writing these
combinations
if i were to say this right if i would
say module here
well but module's not no no no no that
doesn't work either so
hold on what what what do i need to do
here so i'm just saying that's one part
what are we doing here no no what you
could do is
write module parenthesis f
cl close the yeah yeah close the close
the assignment after the the parenthesis
after f
before the uh oh sure sure sure then
then if i say this
and
right and that that works uh i think
there's a
there's a column missing right so
actually
the compiler compiles that especially so
so it recognizes
it it sets up the binding so you can
actually compile these things which
i think and it can do type inferencing
for these things but it would be much
neater
hold on hold on hold on hold on what
you're saying is
and and this is interesting and i i
probably thought about this of
like decades ago um
is the question of
whether there is essentially because
what with is doing is this sort of one
pass
semantics and whether there is a way of
doing this
it's just like applying the land is
defining it i know
i know i know that's what he did so
it's just a different way of writing a
lambda function
and it has the same scoping rules and
everything you see so
um i think this with recursive would be
kind of useful actually and yeah i think
it's not
slight quite the correct design but i
think there is something like this that
will be useful what point but
i'm trying to understand what
it's not okay all right fine so that's
part of the story
can i say another thing there might be
another form of module where you can
only make one assignment
to the variable as well you have to make
one
assignment but you don't have to put it
in because actually
i yeah yeah i mean that's
and it's nice to sort of scatter these
assignments throughout function
well the issue is why
why it doesn't work to do this oh sorry
why it doesn't work
to do this which is a little bit
unobvious to me why this doesn't work
because it makes the assignment because
it doesn't apply uh lex
lexical because it is a lexical thing
which lexically does yes
yes right correct yes on the other hand
if i were to do this
it's hunky-dory yeah
right correct
but but we hate block
this is a more complicated issue this is
not as simple as you're making it out to
be
okay this is i mean i mean
okay again question
um
so point of view of okay this is
discussing automatic differentiation the
perspective of category theory
um
yeah recursive neuron that's a recurrent
neuron that's how does this all work for
this
good question well you enroll them
yes when you buy propagate through time
right okay so um i think richard on our
live stream points out
interesting case which isn't often dealt
with is gradients for infinite impulse
response filters
gpu optimization for which involves
using k fibonacci sequence corrective
terms which are derived by hand
okay so this is rob back in the day
when you were deriving runge-kutta yes
whatever's this is that whole story
again
well see that's that's partly one i mean
i want to mention that's something i
want out of this
this design we come up with is we have a
way of attaching rules
to functions that allow you to define
these so that
so that some some process you know
compilation or whatever would be able to
find those definitions for example you
can define a
a backward rule for linear solve
and so you can find the the derivative
with respect to all the components into
a linear solve
using this using these these
okay so just make a general comment i
mean the good news is in our language
there's a ton of stuff that we already
do without assigning values to variables
some things implicitly assign values to
variables like sum
for example but
mostly we're not you know most people
who are worrying about low-level
languages and automatic differentiation
that code is just full of assignments we
do not have that issue
and so it should be easier for us
to write the code in this essentially
combinator-like form
and i'm a little bit confused by
something like nest
i would have thought there was just a
formula for the derivative here
i mean a formula in a generalized sense
of the term formula
that is i would have expected we could
just derive
am i wrong see there are cases where we
can just derive it
exactly that's that's what i was saying
rob what does your code do for
your differentiate to do for for nest
well ness by the time i get to my
differentiation ernest is
i believe already been unrolled into a
loop
yeah that that's that's the thing and so
it just handles the loop
yes but what about what what's happening
what do you mean by
a a um a code graph yeah it's a
it's a code graph with the loop and and
so
see this is this is a this is a perfect
example so
so if you had an n there you know which
was large
if you actually compute the nth
derivative it's a disaster right
but if you compute one of these four
over to reverse things
it's it's quite efficient because it
doesn't have to do that whole big
expression as well to get the nth
derivative
okay so i have a suggestion here okay
so i'm wondering whether
for a bunch of our functions
i'm wondering whether we could just i
mean we've never tried doing this
whether we can
okay actually no another way to think
about this okay so you've got a code
graph
many of our functions imply a certain
piece of a code graph
correct so my question is
first of all do we have a nice symbolic
way to represent the code graph
and second of all i mean so there are
several pieces to this
can we represent the code graph
symbolically you know the code graph is
not
that different from neural nets and
recursive neural nets and recurrent
neural nets and all this kind of thing
if i'm not mistaken is that correct
that is the code graph right generic
is more expressive you have more
statements you have branches ifs and
stuff like that but essential
the question was can we represent
generic programs with graphs no no no no
no no
it's execution trace i think okay so the
trace is always an acidic graph yes
of course and it's a reducible graph
with what the compiler only produces
reducible graphs
so you know this old function trace
which let me run this one for example
here
turn the 20 into something a bit smaller
i know
i was going to right
okay this function developed in 1991
was an attempt to represent
okay so an interesting sub project is to
make this into a graph
see what would be more useful would be
to generate the graph
that's for the lambda function the x you
know the
the code graph and then to animate
you know visualize the flow of data
through that
well fine but i mean but but this is an
example
okay so this trace here
is an example of something if we turn
this into a graph my guess is
that that see this nest
well this case is awkward this recursive
case is awkward because it has a
arbitrary length but but imagine there
was another parameter here
we could take this thing and we could
say
you know let's hollow out this thing and
and feed our other parameter through the
same execution trace graph
if that makes sense right so in other
words if we can represent this by
graph we can take
you know yeah and then once we have this
graph
am i correct that it's rather
straightforward to do the
differentiation
there's only one output yeah it's
straightforward just by progression
in the case where you have where you
want the jacobian
and you know you have like i don't know
200 input and 50 output and if it's
complete graph
there's actually a very specific way to
apply the chain rule
this optimal way that is hard to find
um that is a it's actually an np hard
problem to find the
yeah so the optimal way to to combine
the derivatives
to change jacobian
well we actually have we actually have
code in the kernel
surprisingly enough with with this
numerical function that uses
it it doesn't it doesn't solve the np
complete problem but
but what it does is it is it
is it it does a dependency dependency
thing and tries to do as few
you know few computations as possible
so it's not optimal but it's close to
optimal
right this was used for our finite
different stuff before
the well okay so listen i mean there's
clearly a bunch of interesting things
here
richard on livestream is pointing out
all kinds of um
things about yes is noticing multi-way
neural nets which
yes are an interesting thing which i
have thought about a bit
and the question of of
points are people are also pushing
gradient through runge-kutta solvers
using adjoint methods for neural odes
yep see that's that's that's part of the
reason i came up with this design
at that so we need to have a design for
that concept and then we could do
we could use adjoint sensitivity for nd
solve in parametric and dissolve and get
these gradients
that's one of the things we could get
out of a good design
right well i think we're going to get a
good design we just it's going to take
us another hour or two
i mean basically this is this is the
thing to be thinking about is what do we
do
to make a function and okay that okay
let me let me parametrize what i think
we have to do
thing number one we need a design for
this thing which i think as i said would
be
the general case is case zero here um
thing number two we then have to be able
to take
pieces of code where we essentially
generate
something very analogous to the output
of trace
right and essentially what will happen
is the output of trace will have a
particular form
but the the numbers will change the
structure will stay the same that's the
case where we can do automatic
differentiation if i'm
if i'm not mistaken is that correct
i mean like loop lengths how do we how
do we deal with the change of loop
length
guys in automatic differentiation yep
well there's there's no problem because
it's once the
program has been executed so no no i
i understand but if if if one of the
parameters
affects the length of the loop how does
that work
in other words if you you know you can't
do that right
if the loop has n elements and that
thing that i gave before
awkwardly which had a floor in the nest
yes what as i mentioned i think you're
out of luck in that case you are out of
luck
because there are there are cases um so
so automatic differentiation can
typically handle
one one point of non-differentiability i
wonder
yeah i wonder whether the disaster and
it gets the floor is fine
the floor is fine because it is just
around the x
if x 2.3 around 2.3 is just 2.
no i know that but at the end the
problem is
in this thing where you're basically
tweaking a co
a code graph your code graph has a
different structure depending on the
value of
x and i don't think you can handle that
well see that's that so so that's an
integer valued thing
floor so basically its derivative is
zero
almost everywhere right okay all right
okay and and the thing is
i don't think that's i don't think it is
a problem it is i don't think it's going
to work but it doesn't matter but let's
just
let me give my out my outline for how we
should do this okay
so my claim is that conceptually
we got this function on the outside we
say okay great
now we've got the inner function we
evaluate it sort of
semi-symbolically to produce an
execution trace
that execution trace
we i don't know exactly what the type
inference pruning of that execution
trace is
i would not be surprised if we couldn't
use our theorem prover
to do a few things here to simplify that
execution trace
but in any case but be that as it may
then
given the execution trace there are
essentially symbolic parameter points
you could call them in the execution
trace that are the places that you can
wiggle
to get the derivatives if that makes
sense
right and the outer function is defining
you know this execution trace probably
doesn't care
it may have you know three input
dimensions five output dimensions
that means there are you know lots of
parameters you can wiggle
in here but you only are interested in a
particular
uh you know you're only interested in
whatever the projection is for case two
and one and two here
so then my claim is that
it then becomes so if you can write this
and it may be really straightforward it
may be really straightforward given
that that we have a symbolic structure
from traced
to create this code graph basically
that then allows us i mean maybe we
don't even have to invent all of this
combinator stuff
maybe it already exists just by looking
at the execution trace here
i'm not sure requires thought
um okay i think i need to go because i'm
late for something else
um but uh okay this is very helpful i i
never really dug in properly to the i
should have done years ago
to this question because this is
actually i i think that
yeah i think we're going to be able to
do something really good here and
my guess is that the main role of the
compiler will be
in essentially simplifying this
general symbolic representation of the
execution
you know graph
that would be my guess and it requires
plus it may be well
my guess also is that that we actually
just need to derive
derivatives of a bunch of our functions
yes
yes i think i think we need to do that
right so important language
implementations for them
no i don't think we want to do that i
think we want to get a nice optimized
piece of code
that is the derivative of a nest
or it is the derivative of something
more
obscure i mean but but yes that problem
is not that different from seeing how to
compile that function down to what ends
up as low level code
but it isn't quite the same thing
because what we want
here i mean is a little funny because
look i could imagine
like our old line calculus folk
actually coming up with formulae
for the derivatives of a bunch of our
plus you know our functional programming
uh constructs okay as
formulas basically and those formulas
may contain other functional programming
constructs that are quite compact and
quite efficient and even quite readable
but you could also write everything in
terms of low level on
you know loops and things like this that
the compiler would want to generate
because that's what the low-level
machine code stuff is going to be while
it's generating that they're actually
they look like loops but they're really
function calls you see
well that may be but the fact is i'm
saying there's two different objectives
here
one objective what
fine yeah one objective would be
take a piece of functional code and make
an actual human readable derivative for
it
that may not be possible i don't know
it may be that that it takes only that
that just like that we could have a nest
prime function
just like you know we have a function
zeta prime that's the derivative of this
data function
which has its its own code that does
things
right i mean i'm sure if i do numerical
value that'll just give a value
right so we could imagine something very
bizarre
where we have essentially a nest prime
d do you get what i'm saying where in
other words we're taking our functional
programming constructs and we are
defining
you know either explicitly represented
or formal derivatives of them
symbolically
see what i'm saying
yep sure um
i think this is the way to think about
this all right i gotta go
um all right thanks guys and um
thanks to folks on the live stream a
bunch of interesting comments there
and